hi welcome everybody I'm Liz Landers I'm
Vice news's Chief political
correspondent and we are here today to
talk about some of the biggest issues
dividing women across the country in
other words we're here to talk about
feminism
first I just want to say we know we
can't represent everybody's views but we
did try our best to bring together a
diverse group of women today in today's
polarized world is feminism dead
you guys saw your hand I think that the
pencil and definition of feminism I
strongly think that feminism is more of
an action than an identity I would say
it's uplifting all women in which case
it's very alive at the same time if we
do follow that definition feminism has
splintered off into so many different
areas that you can look at people like
Cheryl Sandberg who say you should just
get another Nanny if you feel oppressed
and if we're talking about that kind of
feminism
um yeah it's pretty dead yeah I mean as
long as the human race exists feminism
feminism will never be dead it's
something that we're going to have to
strive and work work towards
um to make sure that there's equality so
feminism is not dead I don't know that
it can die as long as there's power and
oppression there will be people fighting
for equity and
um until that somehow goes away feminism
is Alive and Well I think feminism isn't
actually about equality it's about
equality when it benefits us I think
feminism
it's really about women wanting special
privileges and treatment
at the expense of men often and I think
it's alive and well sadly
I think feminism is also alive and well
um
there are different kinds of feminism
right like that is obvious
um and I for me as as a womanist as a
black feminist right as someone who's
really thinking about human rights
dignity right Equity right as long as
that's not that need isn't met we're
still going to keep fighting I'd say
it's alive and well I'd say that it's
also very nuanced and I think what it
looks like is going to differ depending
on where you are in the world for me I
just see it as a lens which isn't
necessarily antagonistic or uh
protagonistic it's just a useful tool
similar to what Pearl just said I find
that a lot of feminist ideology and
thought today feels more of like a
supremacist movement rather than
something that is supposed to be
advancing the goals of equality I don't
think that we can really turn what's
going on as feminism because it looks so
different to I think the earlier
feminist movement so in that way I would
say it's taken its last breaths of life
it's dying yeah I definitely think it's
getting more and more radicalized for
sure so it's it's definitely still alive
I think I'll preface and say that I
don't know so much about modern Western
feminism and there might be a lot of
terms that I don't know know like
political jargon and stuff
but I believe in the advancement of
women whoever considers themselves a
woman I think there's a deficiency in
society so it's deeply rooted that
feminism has always existed
I think America is a little obsessed
with themselves and like always feminism
is rooted in America and like oh white
women started it and it's kind of
offensive because for thousands of years
women have been dying for their rights I
think as a black woman specifically when
you talk about feminism yeah the
mainstream first thing you think about
is a certain type of feminism that tends
to exclude still even today even with
intersectional feminism exclude
African-American women and it's always
kind of done that and also upper middle
class white women has predominantly been
the face of what we quote unquote
consider feminism I think feminism is
attempting to say okay the first thing
we agree on is that there are barriers
in friction to what I need and what I
want based on the fact that I'm a woman
what it ignores is that and what
privilege is is that you may not have to
think that being a woman and being a
black woman and being a black woman who
has a disability for example impacts you
further you have more barriers you have
more friction you you are less able to
get what you want you're undervalued in
a way that's like
okay well you know that's life that's
what I mean by equity and that we're
able to without friction all get the
same needs met yeah
um yep yeah see I disagree with that I
think life is easier if you're a girl
um actually I think I think there's a
lot of benefits that men don't have I'm
not going to speak anything to race I'm
just talking about gender specifically
it's usually like an excuse like
honestly I think as a girl you have
equal opportunity in the world I think
there's benefits like for example we
have quotas for women in specific jobs
that are given to us that aren't given
to men so yeah I would I would say it's
easier being a girl just from a
Viewpoint over here though it seems
there's a lot of privilege pretty
privilege in what you're saying and that
you're white and you present do you
think I'm pretty thank
that beauty standards have accepted and
so they call me ugly on the internet all
the time they be roasting me daily I
swear to God I don't mean to say I think
you're Gorge I just mean that there are
a certain value that we give to certain
bodies I mean let's also dig into why
these quotas exist and why these um what
you're calling because it's a special
treatment
um no it's because they're have
historically and presently and most jobs
been fewer women and because of sexism
how is it sexism when we have no
barriers today so we can we can pick it
doesn't happen women don't have very
what's stopping you as a woman as a
woman as a woman as a woman as a woman
that ignores a lot that I'm a woman with
a disability so there's a lot stopping
me that you don't have to think about
well as I said before I'm speaking about
women I'm not you're speaking as you're
speaking for yourself you're speaking as
able-bodied woman woman
of course of course there's going to be
other barriers if you're disabled I'm
sure like I'm not I'm not I'm not I'm
talking about as a woman so you're just
gonna ignore it women have it easier yes
I would agree what you're just gonna
ignore the pay Gap um regulation over
your body
the industries that women picks there's
a pig out but it's because women don't
want to do the hardest Industries
I don't think it's that simple I think
like I think that's just a nerve
simplification I think the fact of the
matter is that women structure their
lives differently to men men don't give
birth men don't have have to carry
pregnancies men don't have to be the
primary caregiver most of the time women
also don't hold jobs for as long as men
do they often will stop and start
they'll go back into work they'll take
time off they'll take part-time jobs the
way that men work and women work are
astronomically different and to try to
say that they're comparable is is where
this issue comes from they're not
comparable two things first of all let's
dig into why they think that they should
take these jobs which is society
societal sexism and then also
um actually all I mean Department of
Labor All statistics at least speaking
in the U.S
um have found that when compared for the
same jobs there still is a pay Gap
particularly when it pertains to race
because 60 of women have never asked for
a raise so how can you complain about
your pay by the way what happens
it is a very privileged label right to
be able to say that you're feminist
right and I say that because I Come From
A working class background of Dominican
immigrant parents my mother would not
necessarily identify as a feminist I
look to my mother and I do think of her
as a feminist a lot of my ideas and my
empowerment comes from seeing her like
survive and put food on the table when
I'm thinking about feminism I'm old as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible